en 1990 le procureur général de La Réunion
achète un terrain dont la
parcelle où les runes de la
Sucrerie attribuées par le
Musée Historique du Nam entre en contact avec l'
Association pour la sauvegarde du patrimoine
l'Association Sham devo moindre Oracle
un chantier architectural pour conduire
et  prévoir une opération globale de valorisation
de cet ensemble patrimonial qui
est un témoignage de l'
architecture industrielle encore présente sur l'île
mais en voie de disparition un camping d'ouvrage est mis en place
dans le but de concentrer le site
conformément au
traitement global du bâtiment et
dans le respect de l'authenticité
privilégiant principalement la réutilisation du
matériel existant en tenant compte d'une
dimension sociale le chantier s'inscrit dans une
démarche de formation et d'
insertion professionnelle destinée à un public local de
jeunes adultes ou de chômeurs de longue durée
il n'exclut pas les
associations bénévoles de santé  ponctuellement
écoles et centre de loisirs
durant les quatre années
de 1991 à 1994 des interventions ont été
entreprises selon les méthodes
efficaces pour les monuments historiques
le site est nettoyé et déblayé pour
permettre une meilleure lisibilité des
différents bâtiments de l'usine et
du  identification des zones distinctes
de production les travaux de maçonnerie sont
entrepris les travaux de moellons les
travaux de taille de pierre les travaux d'enduit pour consolider et
stabiliser les pièces que
vous